[Musica]
conoscete questa città
immagino molti di voi lo conosceranno in
mezzo a questa cava di ardesia una
definiva il poeta francese paul valéry
genovese adozione mi sono un'infinità di
piccoli mondi da scoprire
scendiamo meglio questi questi tetti
d'ardesia in piazza finelli una piccola
piazza sita tra sottoripa e antichi
portici che una volta davano
direttamente sul mare il carrubo smile
attuale via san luca
entra nel palazzo pinelli il palazzo
vedete nell'immagine dietro di me lo
superiamo portone la prima rampa di
scale e ci troveremo davanti una parete
magnificamente ricordate dalla gioni
ragioni sono piastrelle maiolicate che
anticamente decoravano molti palazzi
sono storico genovese
ma non solo il campagna di sant'agostino
a pochi passi col teatro esattamente la
conoscete possono vedere subito è
anch'esso interamente rivisto da queste
antica forma d'arte
il termine ragione deriva dall'arabo al
suleja parola platt origine dallo
spagnolo azulejos ea napoletana regione
i ragioni sono senza dei testimoni di
quel melting pot di quella mescolanza di
culture e spese artistiche dei popoli
che si affacciano su mediterraneo ed è
proprio it sono proprio i traffici di
giro dopo nel mediterraneo che fanno sì
che questa forma d'arte giunga a genova
in città vi sono numerosi palazzi che
hanno ancora ragioni conservati lungo
scaloni e le logiche
uno di questi è proprio il nostro
palazzo pinelli sono stati amo
attentamente un ragione
noteremo tre piccoli difetti
essi sono dovuti alla cultura durante la
cottura e la jolie venivano impilati
medianti 3t distanziatori una volta
finita la cultura venivano staccati e
rimanevano a tre piccoli difetti cioè
tre piccole carenze di smalto ragioni
note venivano cotti con la faccia
rivolta verso il basso per fare in modo
che non vengono intaccate durante la
cottura dalla cenere e che intaccasse le
rovinasse ciò ha fatto si ficca quindi
essi abbiano ancora oggi studiano però
oggi piccole colate di colore o piccoli
difetti
essi fanno parte della loggia primo
piano del palazzo pinelli se vi capita
di andarci vedrete che accanto e ragione
vi sono due sedute di ardesia
qui si devono le donne e le 500 a
parlare tra loro e osservare senza
essere osservate i passanti che lì sotto
passava una punta nella in piazza
pinelli
mi è capitato spesso di vedere nei
proprio lì in queste sedute l'ardesia e
nel silenzio mi sembrava da un momento
all'altro il veder comparire una donna
del cinquecento oppure ascoltare le voci
dei passanti
qui sotto passavano magari in carrozza o
tre nati dall età sulle loro portantine
ecco una delle cose che più mi affascina
dei vicoli e genova che vorrei
trasmettervi è proprio questa
i palazzi sulla sua rivale genova con la
loro secolare storia mi danno la
possibilità di vivere per un attimo la
vita degli altri di persone vissute
centinaia di anni fa mi piace definirlo
un salto nel passato a pochi metri da
casa
torniamo ai pinelli questa famiglia si
sa da libri storia fece fortuna
commerciando con la spagna sotto dominio
arabo ed in particolare con siviglia
ed è proprio siviglia che troviamo
ancora oggi la casa christie's si fece
edificare casa dello spinello con la
magia rete anch'essa spenta mente
decorate da ragioni usciamo da palazzo
pinelli direzione sottoripa prima di
aggiungere le policies da ripa dovremmo
imboccare uno stretto vicolo dico
pinelli si abbassano lo sguardo potremo
notare ancora oggi evidenti i segni che
le ruote cari ha lasciato nei secoli
io altre cariche da partiva da piazza
caricamento dove caricavano appunto alle
merci per giungere poi dicendo alla
città abbiamo finalmente piazza in pole
sisto ripa piazza caricamento
se dove affascina spettatore una torre
medievale torre dei morti
prima però di alzare lo sguardo verso
questa torre diamo un occhio alle pietre
che fanno da base questa torre
all'imbocco dello stretto vicolo di qom
orchi come noterete via una scritta il
no rifacimento delle facciate del sito
storico genovese come in questo caso ha
fatto sì che scritte come questa
adesso i muri tra la polizia alleata
1945 siano ancora oggi visibili su
scritte fatte apposta per evitare che i
soldati sia ad entrassero nei vicoli e
nei loro pericoli risse furti
prostituzione forse qualcosa si ancora
oggi e quindi è giusto che se ne ancora
evidenti al giorno ad oggi la scritta
riesca anche si vede poco lecita di
strip off limits to all the light trucks
la scritta così dire poco evidente
perché si teme un piccolo caruggio vide
propri striscioni messi nei vicoli più
larghi facevano a perimetro storico
genovese
e questi diciamo questi canaloni come
vedete diceva a oltre bones è off limits
area biondi saint come sto facendo così
i soldati erano avvertite puntino
entrare nei vicoli come dicevo prima nei
vicoli più stretti vi era quella scritta
cava per la scritta scritta sui muri
oltre ad essa spesso virò un cavalletto
quindi un impedimento proprio fisico
allentando i vicoli con scritto danger
pericolo quel più evidente di così non
andati ma arrivati in piazza caricamento
alziamo lo sguardo vedremo una
bellissima torre porre dei morti e
savona le tantissime torri che
costellavano il suo storico genovese nel
medioevo costruita con grosse pietre di
bonate e con alla vedetta la all'altezza
come te sulla sommità una triplice oltre
gli archetti questa torre splenda
insieme al vicino palazzo nota centro
ospita un famoso albergo l'hotel croce
di malta in questo hotel suonavano a
personaggi del calibro di james fenimore
cooper l'autore delle ultime mohicani
henry james scrittore americano che
giunse a genova nel 1877 e così dice
dall'albergo piuttosto sporco ma anche
la casa più grande avvio aveva evitato
mary shelley che giusta genova nel mio
122 dopo che il marito
poveretto era annegato nel golfo della
spezia stendhal mark twain e infine
anche in italiano giuseppe verdi che
come saprete avuto ha preso casa a
genova ma prima di prendere a casa viene
ospitato in questo hotel mi capita
spesso o immaginerete
di passare su questi porci e per un
attimo
chiudo gli occhi e penso a chi 28
incontrare nell'ottocento a girare a
scrivere ad annotare sul proprio diario
quello che vedeva a raccontarle posteri
diciamo a vivere con aver visto io
l'esperienza da genova la turista
vi domanderete perché proprio tutto
l'hotel croce di malta ebbene leggendo
le cronache dell'epoca veniamo a sapere
questo tel
era un e più esclusivi della città è
sicuramente quindi tanto faceva la
passaparola di chi c'era già stato
ma non solo si racconta che alla darsena
in dogana luogo dove tutto e dove
arrivava la gente di amara genova vi
fossero personaggi che suggerivano boves
dove alloggiare questo perché perché una
volta parte i turisti all'hotel comaschi
malta avrebbero ricevuto
dall'albergatore un lauto compenso o
immaginerete molti se persona
suggerivano appunto di andarlo a tell
croce di malto
ma non solo andiamo a sapere di un tale
un medico che giunto a genova
chi è semplicemente mi scusi mi può
portar l'hotel santa marta e senti così
rispondere ma signore il santa marta
ma non sa che nata a fuoco ma venga con
me che l'ha portata al procedimento
il turista se se la sentiva come dire a
puzzare decise che senti opposto
insospettivo e se di farsi portare la
stessa l'hotel santa marta un
bell'albergo ma sicuramente il nostro no
il nostro croce di malta e quindi
diciamo così l'omino che doveva portarla
all'hotel non avrebbe ricevuto con lauto
compenso comunque specie molta lo stesso
e al rispetto delle malelingue
lo trovo sano e salvo è pronto ad
accoglierlo c'è anche chi una sorta di
tripadvisor ante litteram suggeriva di
dare come nome il croce di malta buon
arbitro nardò dell'analisi dell'anno
dove alloggerete ma attenzione quando
contratte rete con il facchino il prezzo
state attenti perché la distanza della
dogana e l'albergo è davvero poca
insomma c'era modo e modo di farsi
fregare giustamente ecco vedete come
immaginerete leggere e per me le storie
di queste persone che ha vissuto anche
una sottospecie di questo albergo mi dà
l'idea di vivere l'emozione di vivere
anche un loro il loro soggiorno ma non
solo di vivere anche l'agente bozzo
agente ska
ed ecco con le deval a genova dell'epoca
un turista che proprio da tecnici di
malta venne ospitato soggiorno e che
dalle stanze del suo hotel della stanza
dell'hotel dipinse appunto il porto di
genova
in questo acquarello che vediamo con vi
raccontano prima tra i tanti che furono
ospitati costate tv james fenimore
cooper d'autore l'ultimo dei mohicani
che giunse a genova il 27 febbraio del
e così scrivono amico sono acqua de
malta che affaccia direttamente sul
porto non puoi capire l'emozione di
guardare le navi in porto di ascoltare
le grida dei marinai e di annusare
l'odore commercio che immagino sia stato
fritto misto o comunque l'ora di
mangiare che c'è ancora oggi vive in
quei luoghi in continua così ieri ho
passato il porto meticolosamente con il
diletto di un ragazzino scatenato come
immaginerete questa definizione lo
faccio volentieri mia e anzi dovrei vuol
dire fregata sono vere l'avessi
raccontata oggi immagine in cui mi trovo
molto tra i tanti che qui soggiornano
bianche vi fu anche mark twain parto e
di giusta genova nel 1867 e vedeva come
la città dei bei palazzi e gli dice una
città che ha molti bei palazzi dentro
sono sontuosi mentre esternamente
malandati e senza senso
quando cita architettonica hanno bei
saloni grandi muri di pietra e scalinate
lastricate di marmo con pareti grandi
ritratti di rubens tiziano veronesi e
ritratti di antenati inermi piumati 2 in
poi innovato le donne innamorato delle
donne genovesi dice che genova la
superba sarebbe un ottimo titolo se ci
si riferisse alla sensualità delle sue
donne
mark twain è letteralmente rapito dalla
bellezza e le donne di genova che lui
osserva passeggiare soprattutto a chi
vuoi a genova sapete all'acquasola un
parco genovese di certo la città dove
lui spesso va e rimane incantato dalla
bellezza delle donne genova non sapremo
mai se il nostro marche si è riuscito a
conquistare il cuore di qualche genovese
di sicuro tutti conosciamo il suo
aforisma nel quale il letto è definito
come luogo per i cose del mondo
in quanto vi muore generalmente
l'ottanta per cento della popolazione
leggere le parole di martin sua mia
città mi ha fatto molto riflettere da
piccino ho letto due soli de chevet e
immagine avete letto anche voi le
avventure di tom sawyer e le avventure
di huckleberry finn sono libri per me
spettacolare emozionanti e spesso mi
sono immaginata di essere lì con loro a
fare marachelle quindi questi monelli su
mississipi questi luoghi che non ho mai
visto quindi lucro o poi o meno però mai
vista l'epoca quindi meravigliosi anche
comunque stau rea di leggenda
ebbene loro tra di questi libri colui
che li è nato e cresciuto sua bontà
della vita e che scrive che si luoghi
per me così meravigliosi subito alla sua
vita lascia tutto va via e viene qua
nella mia città nella mia genova e
rimane entusiasta da lei
ecco alla luce delle mie di quanto vi
raccontato finora e della mia esperienza
del girovagare di vicoli e nello
studiarli anche quello che vorrei
trasmettervi il mio what matters è
proprio quello di non smette di stupirvi
di avere quando camminate in un luogo
che non conoscete una volta stessa città
come capita a me gli occhi dei bambini
il diletto
il ragazzino scatenato come diceva jeans
primo occupati scrivendo la sua
esperienza girava con lo sguardo
entusiasta mi deve invogliare la
riflessione
oggi vi ho scritto un piccolissimo
fazzoletto di terra ma anch'esso ha in
sé una gemma multi fa cetica tantissimi
tesori da scoprire
la mia esperienza mi ha portato a mar
contare genova la mia città ma ciò vale
per tutto il mondo non lasciate che ciò
che vi circonda sia solo un palazzo una
torre un bel paesaggio qualcosa che mi
scivola addosso anche una piccola
piastrella deve invogliare la
riflessione studiate scoprite studiate
la storia di quel luogo e quando
ritornerete mi sembra come di
riconoscerla sempre diventerà o come
parte di voi vi sembrare ascoltare le
persone che gli hanno vissuto i fatti
che gli sono accaduti
insomma diventerà parte di voi
i quali senza perlo avrete fatto un
salto nel passato a pochi metri da casa
grazie
[Applauso]